[Music]
five years five that is so short a
window it's basically not believable at
all all these cars are shown here
shortly to be in line to buy gasoline
because apparently there's a shortage or
something but look how many of them are
wasting gas idling here in this line
instead of shutting the car off their
horn in traffic when it has no chance of
moving and think the honking is funny
because people is starving should I had
fewer babies then society pee dripping
what is he doing here they're supposedly
working through why the test failed but
they're all standing around holding
nothing no one's writing anything down
this looks like a pep talk more than
anything else and it's hilarious it
could be telling a dirty joke right now
holy it was day 16 the test failed and
in the movie Yatta Yatta at over 80 days
can't wait until we see ten clover me
Lane and the clover knee paradox both of
which will have very little to do with
clover knee man this movie is going so
fast it's like a theme park ride we have
enough fuel for three more firings
always the fucking fuel man Jesus Christ
ten minutes into this supposed
Cloverfield sequel no things happened
and yet I am still not entertained
that's the very opposite of a paradox
you know it would have been cool and
expanded Cloverfield universe where the
films were planned from the start to be
part of the Cloverfield universe instead
of being bought square and shoved into a
round hole also what a weird place for
the title why not do this back during
all the dramatic music and the other
credits this is anticlimactic you've
been pricks you have three firings left
to save the entire world this is not the
time for foosball yes it sure is amazing
that this entire crew can speak Mandarin
to the one Chinese person on the ship
was it required for the absolute top
scientists on this mission to also know
Mandarin just in case their engineer was
Chinese you know how many professional
leagues would have loved one no
micromolar growth nothing you know why
this is a long speech fuck off this guy
buries the lead with some long speech
about how he does his job when what he
really wants to say is MIT because
you're German I think you're purposely
being up our mission to screw the
Russians on earth over why can't we just
get to that Germany is preparing for war
and every day that goes by
more and more Russians are starving
earlier Michael told Ava that the
Russians were planning a ground invasion
in the UK but since then two years have
gone by and we have no fucking clue
what's going on down on the planet other
than vague snippets of dialogue this
movies been so eager to not be
Cloverfield it forgot to be everything
else - you're not in such a hurry to get
the Shepherd working there are so many
legit reasons for there to maybe be
tension on this station but you want
Russians to suffer so you are
intentionally sabotaging the device
which means everyone will suffer is a
pretty stupid one if you ask me
paradoxes also Donna Loeb plays Marc
Stambler and I guess he's related to
Howard Stambler aka John Goodman from 10
Cloverfield Lane and the interviewer
Suzanne Cryer who played the chick who
tried to get inside Howard's house that
died in that movie I guess what I'm
trying to say is I who though cares why
are the astronauts right before is super
important one of three remaining tests
watching the talking heads on TV News
debating the experiment don't you have
something to be doing could the movie
give us the talking heads and some other
way without it being the astronauts
watching it this experiment this guy is
right the Shepards experiments will
cause dimensions to collide with each
other leading to the Cloverfield monster
on earth that's hardly the point of this
movie it's a big MacGuffin that ties
into the franchise but it also seems to
contradict the first movies monster
origins but because we're now talking
about multiple dimensions and multiple
earths I guess anything is possible now
making it less likely for me to care
well turn also a monk why'd you have
that on in the first place now the space
scientists will pray before the big
experiment there's the solution Easter
Egg for all you Cloverfield fanboys
that's why you're here right
let's electro guy
why wasn't this already on the screen
isn't this the experiment queue it isn't
this Hamilton plays the pronoun game so
that everyone has to ask what the hell
it means if I find anything
see experiment space goes wrong earth
disappears should be a much better movie
than this one just on premise alone yet
here we are she can't find Mission
Control signal she can't find any other
signal they're pretty sure earth is gone
and her next experiment is to try to
Skype her husband like once she sees she
can't do that
well she truly believed Earth is gone
now also isn't it weird that after
concluding Earth was gone none of them
tried to look for Mars or Venus or the
moon or any other sign that it was the
earth for sure that moved and not their
space station found the problem with the
gyre Hamilton is the dramatic reveal
scientists always making you guess what
the fuck is going on if we're telling
you what's going on later we find out
this guy's got not only this entire tank
full of worms inside of him he also has
the gyro inside of it the very idea that
he isn't immediately dead from that is
mind-boggling but horror movies got a
horror I guess this chick from the
sovereign magically appears on the ship
with some of the ships wires running
through her weird right but it appears
the chaos predicted by Professor Donald
Logue it's just random bolt as if they
have a heart of gold and probability
drive on it this Russian dude gets
filled up with worms they brought up to
space Chris are down from bridesmaids
deals with a dickhead ship panel and
even the ship itself appears to be from
a parallel dimension and oh yeah the
Cloverfield monster shows up on earth
other than that kind of a win right
certainly better than what happened
after the 2016 presidential election
that panel is not thick enough were made
of any material that could have made her
human screaming sound the way it did
before they remove the panel
I'm just saying also this whole scene is
gross Hamilton certainly is a great
musical but I doubt it can help you out
of the situation
she'll said what did it will be tries to
keep the Cloverfield monster a surprise
for getting we've seen Cloverfield we're
definitely not in Kentucky anymore
Kansas Kansas really gives people some
kinds of smoke dump Oh even people in
Kansas care probably glad Kentucky's
getting this overused line for a change
oh no no something causing the foosball
table to go crazy maybe it'll have
anything to do with the plot of this
movie at all you're saying it doesn't I
thought we were about to see the ghost
of Frederick Colin yan haunt this ship
Hey worms amazing just wondering why the
did they bring warms up here if the
experiment is to find a source of
unlimited energy just what are the worms
do damn it now we may never know worms
can be trained to sort tiny screws in
space how you focus and you can just
understand she does which makes me
wonder why everyone's decided to polish
off their Mandarin to talk to her the
whole movie say uncle Mac she's in the
window that was shopping oh man this
experiment turned her into Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon I'm not 50 cents off
I'll say again the sky is filled with a
tank full of overgrown worms and the
ship's gyro and this is all that's
happening to him stop showing people
puking in movies it's amazing that gun
doesn't go off during this seizure given
his terrible trigger discipline oh we
found the worms that Russian guy died
Tim so alternate realities and
teleportation I'm not saying I'm against
it but I am saying it's probably a bit
much whatever I feel like I could go
watch the Star Trek The Next Generation
episodes yesterday's enterprise in
theory and parallels and get ten times
the enjoyment as I will from this movie
but still have the same themes explored
although in theory really isn't all that
great an episode it's just that it has a
dude who gets phased halfway into the
floor and stuck there so that's why it's
included but the other two episodes are
dope-ass all-time classics who you what
do you mean Who am I
it's me Nina in the parallel universe
Jensen lives in she's friends with
Hamilton and things are different enough
that Hamilton's kids are still alive but
how are things that's significantly
different without being almost totally
different Jensen was on the Cloverfield
ship with nearly the exact same crew -
Tam and Hamilton it's impossible that
this parallel universe has just a few
minor differences without changing the
entire planet this is butterfly effect
type even the slightest change could
make the world unrecognizable to you and
me goddamn insane that there's even the
same people on this other earth
[Music]
sabotage this okay you heard everything
else she had to say and didn't believe
she was previously aboard this station
but she says that and suddenly you're
curious have you lost your minds a movie
thinks it's so smart but I am NOT lost
not yet clearly it was Schmidt in
another reality that was a saboteur but
the one here was not and it seems damn
obvious what's the word for when the
characters take three times as long as
the audience to reach conclusions that
should be obvious yes I remember it's
called the Cloverfield paradox I mean is
whatever causing this a horror movie
villain I get the dimensions or
colliding and whatnot but it seems to
have a Freddy Krueger mindset I like
Chris O'Dowd a lot but this character
must be taking all the best space drugs
if he reacts to everything in a comic
relief sort of way my crowbar this is
exactly what I said to my college
girlfriend after we all so this movie is
starting to feel like they had a
brainstorming session but didn't veto
any ideas and then went and wrote the
script particles interacting with each
other across two dimensions two distinct
realities in a multiverse fighting to
occupy the same space creating chaos or
just mild inconveniences seriously the
idea is brought up by this movie are
actually too big for the movie they're
in calm calm oh I say we do what the arm
says also since you're a disembodied arm
that can write like this why not just
tell them what's in volkoff's body
already
how did monday's arm know this was
inside volkoff's body is the arm
sentient because that has a weird
existence but we're hoping that the
piece of equipment you found in
someone's stomach is what's gonna save
the day you gets in the movie while
you're shooting the movie we have to get
the Shepherd fixed and fired again what
we know about quantum entanglement
dictates it should bring us back if you
say so
you only just realized fully what has
transpired here but you know the
solution so well that again makes me
wonder why it took you so long to figure
out the situation you shouldn't tell me
god dammit little girl that's my line
bad things happening but good people are
gonna make it better no they want it's
not a mediocre space movie without a
discount Titanic near-drowning scene 1
luckily during the crash of dimensions
the Cloverfield paradox sent a
replacement engineer to this ship who
can take Tam's place
oh no no tell you what let's put a pin
in this discussion right here walk over
to the mid Bay where the girl you're
suggesting we replaced am with is
sitting and then finish the debate
they're savvy shoppers
how can anyone on this station ask this
question with a straight face anymore
nothing of mine would fit you you'd
better try this the only clothing that
could fit the 6-foot 3 inch tall Jensen
is the equally tall Monday so why did
she bother saying anything about her own
clothes just say these are Monday's
clothes he's the only person told up on
the ship to provide you clothing where
else would they be Kansas of course
they'd be on earth that's why you so in
the other world Hamilton didn't go so
she could stay with the kids but in the
photo it shows that nobody replaced her
so why did this world need her on the
ship and the other world said we don't
need no Hamilton or anybody like
Hamilton
so we turn off the other to promise fire
the Shepherd's then Ruth the power
generated by the now operational
Shepherd we start the pumps that's it's
also the exact thing they did in Apollo
so maybe Apollo 13 is quick Jesus Christ
Hamilton you play the pronoun game more
than actual pronouns do you definitely
play more pronoun games than Rudolph the
red-nose she so stupid Ava tells the
commander that she's going to stay
behind in this reality because her kids
are alive here even though she knows
there's another her already caring for
the kids she has no place here she's
just gonna watch stock the kids like
Miss Piggy and Muppets Take Manhattan I
guess because she is stupid Ava that's
not your family down there that's hers
I'm looking forward to the Cloverfield
spin-off Gugu mbatha-raw you want to see
two goo Goo's fighting for the right to
be there living mother come see the raw
emotion the raw conflict the souls bear
raw rated raw I mean R for raw it's down
there once the same thing I do I know
her she'll steal energy for her family
just like I did and they won't survive
okay
keel allows this even more once don't be
armed I think I can get this done
he sure has adjusted well and rapidly to
having one arm like most people would
need months of therapy
he's been cracking jokes about it since
like five minutes after it happened well
I watched him put magnet putty on the
wall I'm reminded of the last time he
was doing this when the wall ate his arm
which then showed up later doing its own
thing are we ever going to explain that
you think with interdimensional clashing
crazy would be happening all the time
but in this movie it's very selective
about doing crazy only when the plot
demands it
how did none of the metal thing slamming
into this metal wall set off a spark
remember they said he died in a fire
explosion if a single spark went off
while he was surrounded by oxygen you
mean they never bothered to look over at
the screen until Monday was completely
screwed weren't they trying to contact
him a minute ago wouldn't checking the
monitor have been a good thing so you're
telling me they're gonna do something to
fix this that was somehow a lot of
shepherd to still work cuz if so all
that thanks Gil like the whole reason
you're up here is because of that very
obvious thing you just said I literally
don't care what happens Marvin the
Martian and Michael Jordan could swing
by and save the day and I'd be fine
just so long as this thing ends it was
the last time the final 20 minutes of a
movie felt like three hours Return of
the King maybe of course it is also he'd
be able to move it if he did the Mokhtar
chant of strength you know what are you
doing compute couple the ring at this
point has to be locked we can do
something with the ship but the failsafe
makes somebody have to sacrifice
themselves to work Lee shit Jesus every
time we cut back to the husband and the
little girl an already boring movie
grinds to a halt well Pat the Shepherd
to fire twice once to overload did you
get us home then again with times
equation programmed in would you give us
the energy we need so in other words
let's do that stupid thing that crashed
the dimensions together in the first
place and that definitely won't cause
any further problems and it'll send us
back to earth for some reason that's not
dimensions crashing into each other work
you can just don't do it by doing the
same thing you did last time this is why
you don't punch our pistol-whip people
you actually want to incapacitate for
longer than a few seconds why would an
escape pod have live-feed multi-monitor
security footage of the inside of the
ship if you ask me if I'm willing to get
to say that 8 billion actually it's 8
billion and to Jensen remember in your
world Hamilton's kids are alive guy who
got shot holding a sudden pipe ex
machina wholly forgotten our Batman also
a Monday is super dead and we still
never got a good explanation for the arm
moving and thinking for itself or the
ghost activity like the spinning of the
foosball guys there's no four keys on
any goddamn wrist pad on her spacesuit
that she can funky in and call up a
specific video and chromecast onto a
nearby TV that is the fakest bulbous lie
this movie ever told goddamnit
whose fight Foo Fighters whatever that
was
Ava fired into the TV and all I can say
is thank god the windows on this station
all double his TVs and that Jenson
decided to send this video from a wrist
to that window TV also spider-man and
Iron Man called from infinity war and
even though their movie came out after
years they are owned by Marvel Disney
Globo gym and are still suing you for a
jillion dollars for stealing their idea
they stole from you but tried to pass
off as an alien's reference GMR I need
you to look happy insanely happy no
happy damn you you would be happy damn
it we need to juxtapose the to use
because it'll be dramatic oh happy
you're not using your mind to promise
I'm you so wait is this an audio
recording I know some got up on the ship
bug does that mean all the cameras
aren't working wouldn't be better if you
did this with video also I think a Total
Recall rip off beat feels oddly
appropriate here at the end of this
movie that's basically a parade of
cribbed sci-fi beats masquerading as an
original film I need to say two things
first don't eat yellow snow second no
one knows what the three seashells do
everyone's just using their hand and
pretending they know how the shells work
also she tells the other her with no
explanation not to steal Power Cells and
tells her to hug her family explaining
the Power Cell thing would explain both
things but it's important to be cryptic
when you're talking to a parallel you
hope this goes on for some time like an
incredible amount of time for a message
that opened with I have to be quick also
she never once says I'm you from an
alternate dimension and I'm here because
my reality Shepard done things up even
though she clearly has time for it yep
that worked they definitely didn't have
the same conditions running that
experiment as they did the last time but
sure overloading the Shepard accelerator
just sent them straight back to earth no
questions asked have a stable beat this
is exactly what I said to my college
girlfriend after having to come
Michael doesn't want Hamilton to come
back because there are Cloverfield
monsters running amuck on the planet
what the what she's supposed to do
is there enough food and oxygen on the
shepherd until they get a bounty hunter
to kill all the monsters do they know
what's happening no there wasn't time we
lost contact either the space
organization is stupid or evil for
letting Hamilton and Schmitt come back
without warning them first
right after she told Huntsville if the
accelerator was working a whole bunch of
people cheer and then they went
immediately to the landing capsule there
was no radio issue at all at that moment
did he eat the lunar capsule uh who
cares this final shot of the monster is
a big view we're never gonna see those
people again anyway the next Cloverfield
will take place during a Steve Carell
comedy the klutz reel all right it's the
female orgasm that's the myth single
cyclotomic filled using the art map we
might induce homomorphisms no one has
been able to accomplish such
constructions yet
hi this is Nikki hi this is Nikki leave
a message
[Music]
Mike Nikki great don't ever call me
again
[Music]
three-two-one
I'm gonna see okay say the Guardian
we're gonna be okay getting from there
to you
[Music]
[Applause]